and finally new rule America needs more
Republicans like this guy this man
should be commended and not just for
being the first Trump voter to get all
the spelling right on a sign but because
it's not easy to admit that you've been
taken by a con man now during the
campaign con man Trump said this about
the high cost of pharmaceuticals and
we're going to get drug prices so far
lower than they are now your head will
spin that's right he promised to use his
deal-making superpowers to to get the
drug companies to cut prices but after
the election he sat down with the
executives of big pharma and what do you
know it turns out the solution isn't to
get tough at all it's to cut regulations
[ __ ] he promised the Keystone pipeline
would be built with American steel it
won't he promised to be the savior of
coal miners but here was the headline
last month
Trump's budget slams West Virginia I
know you real Americans hate being
called stupid but he got to meet me
halfway and stop being stupid
I mean I would say Trump was a used car
salesman but with a used car salesman at
least you get a car with Trump you don't
get any car but you definitely get taken
for a ride
he he promised and I quote we're going
to have insurance for everybody
much less expensive and much better but
when we saw the bill it was a giant tax
cut for the rich paid by kicking 24
million people off their health
insurance what a truly novel approach to
making health care less expensive saving
money by not giving people health care
it's like saving money on your kids
education by letting them stay home and
watch Judge Judy and again I don't want
to use the S word but then you have to
tell me how this sounded at all possible
if you can end up with great health care
for a fraction of the price and that's
going to take place immediately after we
go in okay immediately fast quick
believing health care could be way
better at a fraction of the cost is so
silly let's call it silly the Trump
approach to health care was never going
to be repealed and replaced it was
always bait and switch because
because that is the con man's approach
to everything
did I say health insurance for all I
meant access to insurance
did I say Mexico would pay for the
beautiful wall that keeps drug dealers
out and locks the freshness in I met
Mexico would pay us back I will build a
great great wall on our southern border
and I will have Mexico pay for that wall
act now and we'll throw in a second wall
after
Trump has promised jobs
you're probably wondering will these be
good jobs I'm glad you asked
massive numbers of jobs high-paying jobs
good jobs not the jobs we have today
which everybody agrees are bad job we're
going to create massive numbers of good
job right good job in the burgeoning new
field of something terrific
[Laughter]
you know you Trump stirs you didn't
elect the next Reagan you elected this
guy I invite you to come to my seminar
learn how to make a lot of money once
you have a pace of a good life you will
never go back you will you elected every
cheap huckster who you should have known
this full of [ __ ] because he was always
promising the moon everything is always
foolproof and a hundred percent but it
is a foolproof way of winning the war
with Isis and it will be absolutely a
hundred percent they'll at a minimum
come to the table and actually they'll
be defeated very quickly folks how much
would you pay to get rid of Isis very
don't answer yet because not only will
Isis be gone like that here's our
guarantee on undocumented immigrants
because they going after your pension so
which do you like better winning so much
you're tired of winning or having your
head spin the heads would spin your head
will spin
winnings winning winning your head will
spin winning big leagues it's too much
winnings
we can't take it anymore
order now and we will throw in
everything I will give you everything I
will give you what you've been looking
for 30 40 50 years really yes everything
everything he said okay I won't mock you
anymore you're not the first people to
be fooled by a guy like Donald Trump
what's your name Stanley Kowalski :
going to coincidence Rudi Polanski how
are you no sense crying over spilt snake
oil you can keep liking him but just
admit he is a con man and a good one the
kind who tells you I promise I'll pull
out while he's coming